all right we were we were recording uh
an album with with uh my old band that
we had and we decided we were going to
be
rock stars and sleep in the studio which
is a terrible idea
and the engineer laughed at us he was
like cool bye and left
what the hell studio lets you do that
asc summit studios is no longer there
but it was this
badass studio in in dallas off of uh
greenville avenue
and it was and they just casually let
you sleep there
well imagine trying to do that at like
warner brothers you're like
no hey guys i want to try to bring a
sleeping bag
the our our buddy was the house engineer
and we were doing our record there
and so we were kind of like recording
when they would let us but
we should have been paying like you know
500 to 800 bucks a day
um it was an amazing rate well this was
like also 2000
2001 or whatever so how big a room are
we talking
40 by 40 by 20.
okay so it was huge had three echo
chambers don henley did stuff there's
uh overdose for sticky fingers was done
there from rolling stones
badass studio and you could play like a
pickup game of basketball
in that in that studio and cutter record
but
we had this 13-inch color tv combo vcr
and high rollers yeah dude and our bass
player was like
half our audience doesn't know what half
those right they used to put them in one
kids
here you go here's your birthday present
now daddy's gonna go good i don't even
understand what it means to watch
something that isn't coming through the
internet in real life
what do you mean a hard format so our
bass player was like dude we're gonna
watch vanilla sky
everybody else passes out i stay awake
watching this thing
on like a 13-inch tv and i was blown
away um
but by it was i was like i didn't know
that tom cruise was a good actor
i just thought he was and he's he's
phenomenal
very good i have this thought that the
only reason
that tom cruise gets away with the
scientology thing which i feel like most
people feel negatively about is because
he's a very good actor and everyone
always says he's brilliant to work with
like so long as you show up and you do
your job well people will forgive
quite a bit i think not just coming
across is just a very driven blow it
seems that way
yeah yeah that's what that's what i was
gonna say it's it's not just that i
i hear he's great to work with but he he
is you know the hardest working person
on the production by all reputation
you know it's like not to mention just
the spectacle of like
finding new ways to put himself in
precarious danger with every
new film uh but uh but
like always you know showing up early
and leaving late and and you know
hustling i i always hear about it i feel
like i may have
i probably have told this story here but
um
when friends of mine were working with
michael jacquino on the on the jj abrams
mission impossible three
it was mi3 i didn't realize that i knew
it was one of those but
i couldn't remember which one it was i
love the story so shut up
little little uh little commentary
that's a lot of because he has a metroid
he has a story
it was just that he you know he came to
all the recording sessions
um you might actually you might be
thinking of a different story that
is from him working with hans zimmer on
mission possible two
which is a story much more about han
zimmer than it is about tom cruise but
uh the the aquino one was that he came
to the orchestra sessions and
and was like you know i want to try
conducting the orchestra
and so they they they and the funny
thing is the mission impossible theme is
famously in in in 5'4 i can't not play
it austin
come on now you know what your role is
how do you even know where the keyboard
is behind you to be able to do that i
just don't get it that's that's
day one of music school of arteries
first over the shoulder
[Laughter]
no the uh that so that that theme you
know it's in it's in five for those
unfamiliar very famously so if most
music is you know one two three four
that one has the extra beat you know
quick question is the sidebar so it
makes it feel like it's chasing it's
right that's trying to get ahead
was that carol kay that wrote that line
what line
the bass line or or at least played bass
on that if you don't i'm going to put a
pin in this carol k will come back to it
please continue your story
i don't actually remember who the
original i assume it was just la studio
musicians lalo schifrin
wrote the theme and scored the show um
he was sort of like the definitive
composer of the 70s and 60s you know
it's just that
sound i mean i mean he composed it but
lim biscuit really knocked out the park
dude
i'm pretty sure it was carol k but go
ahead well in any case so
because it's in five it's a little bit
harder to conduct you basically have to
you know you have to count to five and
that's you know it's a stretch
and um so the funny thing is they
they they took they made a diagram for
for
mr cruz to conduct like with the
description of what the physical pattern
is for conducting in five um and there
and they were like just you know
try try to move your arms like this like
there's no sheet music of course it's
pointless but they're like just
just move your hands this way yeah and
he's like yeah sure
sure and uh so he um gets up and you
know it's
it's not easy and especially there's a
hundred piece orchestra sitting here
like i'll let you finish this story but
i'd love to hear you talk about like how
do you learn
to be a conductor oh that's a whole
other yeah for sure
um episode of play watch listen
you forget your instrument and they make
you do it that's how it works
i can tell you the most intimidating way
to learn is in a
100 piece orchestra hollywood studio
orchestra with every musician being
played full
scale uh or or more on a giant
hundred million dollar house no
no that's how tom cruise learned
we are confused regularly but uh
um no so anyway it was what's so funny
is i have a friend who i wasn't there
but i have a friend
uh who was who was there and filmed it
on his phone and showed me
um the footage and what was funny about
it was
that um tom cruise you know he's
basically suffering immensely
like he can't conduct for [ __ ] uh and
it's hard it's already a difficult piece
to conduct like you would have
sympathy for for you know struggling
anyway but what's great is that you know
this is
these hollywood studio orchestras are
just so unbelievable that when you just
if you close your eyes and listen you're
like
that's a 100 perfect take like just
completely in spite of him
the orchestra like he's just wherever he
watch the short dude
yeah and you just hear this you know you
hear this giant rum
so what was cool is that after that he
um he arranged um
they did like a big catering thing where
you know it was like
this you know on the studio lot the big
giant meal and desserts and stuff show a
big giant craft services thing
shows up to take care of the musicians
and then they did a
this wasn't that common it's starting to
become a little more common and he may
have even been he and jj abrams may have
been
kind of the tipping point because i
never heard of this
at least much prior to this but they
when the movie was finished they
arranged a special screening
for only the orchestra and their
families to see the film
um and usually the orchestra has just
forgotten the instantly
even you know even a huge one and even
on a thing where music's very important
it's like the premiere is for the stars
the premieres for the director and the
producers and
you know their fancy friends and things
like that and and fair enough you know
there's only so many people you can fit
even in a huge theater
but um but they they arranged a special
screening
for just the orchestra and their
families on that movie
which i thought was nice and i think jj
abrams has done that
i think he's done that pretty
consistently since then um
that's really nice i mean it is a really
significant part of
everything and people so often let it go
but i was going to ask
if tom cruise were not conducting slash
if there is a
an orchestra with no conductor would
they still be able to play a song if
they know it
or is it like super important in that
regard
so um there is such a thing as
conductor-less orchestras they tend to
be very small
because part of the reason why you need
a conductor is that historically you
know in the
like pre like the broken classical eras
of music so we're talking about you know
the
tail end of the 16th century up to the
mid-18th century orchestras were still
20 30 people so everyone was sitting
pretty close together and so very often
the concert master which is the first
violin
would be the sort of conductor and also
the music tended to be written in a way
where everybody was playing for the most
part all the time
which meant that everybody's listening
off of each other and kind of
getting in the groove and and doing
their thing as orchestral music
started to develop more and more and
become the
new instruments started to be invented
new um
like the the concert venues moved out of
the kind of chamber parlor and the
churches
in which they were traditionally being
done and concert halls
started to become a thing then you
started to enter into this interesting
um
challenge where the orchestra was so
large
that the time delay from musicians
hearing each other across the orchestra
was enough that they could never really
play together
no way yeah like there would be just it
would it would sound like
they're sloppy like they obviously speed
the sound of
sound the speed of sound is quite fast
but it's not fast enough
and on top of that it gets muddied like
have you ever been on a stage
where you're like introducing your
you know i'm sure you've been on plenty
of stages where you're like presenting
an award or whatever or you're or you're
giving a speech
and you you're hearing the slap back of
your own voice off the back wall through
the speakers and how
it's really hard to focus and it's
really hard to pay attention when you're
getting that feedback well
it's essentially the same phenomenon for
orchestras where they're only reliant on
their ears to really
stay together where you're getting
you're not getting the sound you're
getting the reflection of the sound and
it's not quite in sync with
the source point of the sound so that
you wonder if that's more to do with
reaction times rather than like the
speed of sound right because it's it's
actually you're waiting for someone to
hear
and process here we are in my territory
now there's like a millisecond delay
between a sound coming into your ear and
you knowing it's there
so if you multiply that by hundreds of
people yeah that makes sense that's
slower than the speed of sound that
transition in the brain yeah the two
the two combined start to really make it
unfeasible
uh in physics and so i think um
the um the the early days of conducting
like there was a very famous
um uh french conductor named luly who um
was uh he had a giant staff and he would
just pound the beat
like gandalf yeah oh [ __ ] and yeah god
damn it
yeah here's the best part lully is i
think the only conductor who has ever
died in the line of duty because he
stabbed himself in the foot during a
concert and got
gangrene and died oh my god well i don't
think it works quite that fast
i didn't think so either like he didn't
die in the line of duty he just had a
stupid accident and he like
suffered for a couple he was injured he
fell in the line of duty yeah
he was very respectful of the guy we
just left
i think we can just put some bactine or
something we haven't invented bacteria
yet he's going to die
yeah yep sorry for you it is great
concert so don't worry
it's still sad can i please i want to
point out
first of all two things yeah i am the
dumbest person on this podcast i just
want to point that
that is a resounding truth there's so
many conversations where i'm like
i think i'm a fairly intel mental and
textual
i'm a fairly intellectual person
actually i'm one of those intellectuals
man and then i and then i hear you guys
and i go man i'm the dumbest person on
this podcast
okay um but i would love to point out
um a specific person because a lot of
people don't even know this person
exists carol kaye
born march 24th 1935. i was correct she
did play on that she did stuff with
shiffrin
uh in addition to stuff with phil
spector brian wilson quincy jones
she is the most recorded session
musician
in history she's she's part of the uh
wrecking crew is she in that she's part
of the wrecking crew uh
women can't play instruments dude
there's a whole documentary
political what they do yeah it's very
political when women die instruments
she take part why do people keep
inserting that into our music
i remember when music was apolitical
exactly
yeah don't don't bring me your diversity
wokeness in 1957.
um she yeah like basically everything
that's ever had like oh that's badass
bass line
carol k played it like going back to
like i think it was satisfaction but
like
beach boys she played on beach boys
records she's incredible that's where
stuff should brian wilson like i think
it was um
good vibration i think she she played
that [ __ ] i was just talking about it
i was just talking about good vibrations
last night um
how if you saw the movie love and mercy
with paul dano as brian wilson where
there's a scene where they're
really have you seen that movie i
actually haven't no
i it is
literally sitting right here
it's okay it's just now that now now
we've got your version of hotline miami
we're just gonna roll with that so
it's not greg miller anymore
no greg miller is mike's favorite you
get to have a separate
it's true pay off some people at baptist
so that guy didn't get nominated
um yeah that scene go watch that scene
uh
in love and mercy of them recording good
vibrations because what's cool is it's
very
it's it's not really dramatized for the
sake of the movie like it's pretty
accurate to how
they surely did it it's certainly i
don't know the specifics of how
they worked but it's it's certainly
accurate to the way records were made
and are made by and large still um
it's an awesome scene especially because
it's all about brian wilson
and his kind of neurotic obsessiveness
they like yell at him they're like the
cellists have been playing for
three hours and he's like it's not done
and
and uh you know it's like part of me
looks at that and it's like i admire
i admire the insane uh brilliance but
then i also think about the cellists and
i'm like
we don't support that yeah i i remember
i remember uh
witnessing um i feel like it's
not throwing anyone under the bus to
tell this story
uh but i remember once walking into a
coffee shop and i ran into some
la musician friends and i was like you
know how you guys doing and they were
they were like ah man you know it's one
of those days
um and uh and it turns out they hit
quote they had been
coming from uh the session to
the curious case benjamin button and and
it's an unbelievably beautiful score
like it was oscar nominated it lost to
the social network uh
no no sorry what did it lose to king's
speech lost his social network different
display score
can't remember what it lost to off the
top of my head but it was
i thought it was the best score that
year is display and peak
form just so excellent and
um but he was famously
like it word got around of how just and
those sessions were just like what i was
describing just a second ago there's a
queue
where um a harpist uh
well her name doesn't matter there's a
harpist there's a well-known harpist in
l.a disagree
who who well what i mean is like i don't
want to single out
masses and k you know what i mean in
context that's a that's a that's a great
one to clip out of context
um i i i i don't know how
how public this information is there's a
number of harpists
she there's a long beautiful extended
solo
but they had this you know 80 plus piece
orchestra sitting there
and um but there's this unaccompanied
very exposed harp solo
and he made her you know normally if you
have a solo like this that you're going
to want to scrutinize you would book it
on a separate session
because you have 80 musicians sitting
there doing nothing and if
you're gonna do so right yeah exactly so
you got producers saying why are we
paying all these people to do nothing
but then also it's just
it's just evil to subject people to sit
there
to boredom like that you know to me
there's just no purpose you know if i'm
a musician i want to
play and uh so you book your sessions to
efficiently use people's time and if you
don't need the full orchestra
you know that's why we get into this
whole world of the a group the b group
the c
group where you you if you if you know
that ten percent of your cues are going
to be only
you know half the orchestra you book
those on a separate day with half-sized
group you know so that you can really
efficiently use everybody's time and
obviously it saves money in the process
so they didn't do that it was basically
just everybody shows up for every
day of sessions and most of the sessions
used enough of the orchestra that it was
it made sense and it was fine but
there's this one passage that he made
her do like two hours
of this cue and just with everyone
sitting there
and i all these musicians were so like
without doing
your fingers over time like it was
musician
injuries i imagine you can part of it
was that it's actually very delicate
so it was you know it's a very quiet
very but he was getting
real you know harp is famously difficult
to
keep in tune you know and it also just
is a tedious it takes like all day to
even tune the thing because
it's like you know all the strings in a
piano imagine every time you sat down to
play you had to get out your
little tool kit of tuning pegs and i
mean this harp is
harp is one of those instruments that
it's like begging not to exist it's such
a high maintenance
this sounds like the original pitch for
whiplash by the way and some writer came
in and punched it up
you made it more like what if someone
you know what's cool
what if it's a drummer i'm taking that
as feedback
on the concision of my delivery um
oh no j j we what we do is we get jk
simmons instead
and he's like we're going to make him
ripped how insane
how would they want the story about the
overworked harpist for sure
that's what happened two two two uh
random trivia about that film how
insane first off that damian chazelle
was in like his mid-20s
when he made that movie um which is to
me just
that's just bonkers but also the funny
little random thing that the girlfriend
he breaks up with
is supergirl and that makes me laugh
that he
isn't there how about i not made that
link yeah
that it shot
90 in los angeles
yeah i mean that's it's like friends and
seinfeld you know
yeah but i mean carnegie hall there's so
many exteriors of new york they sell it
as new york he's going to
whatever school in in new york it's not
nyu but
um and they shot they shot
all of those in like i think they shot
all their exteriors in like one day
they just grilled their shots
and that's actually closed down new york
yeah
the shedding shots like that that's got
to be hard
a man that's true
i remember when i was living in new york
uh they were shooting
the the tom ticker movie the
international i think it's called with
with um nicole kidman it's kind of a spy
thriller um
um i think that's what it's called um
and but they were shooting that on my
street i remember
thinking you know they have to block the
streets which means there's police
barricades and police cars
and then it was a night shot so they've
got all these big cranes with the
floodlights yep and and you know
takes hours to set all that up they've
got their generators the craft services
they've got all the various uh
trailers for you know nicole kidman and
the the other
uh the director and whomever and and it
was and it's a shot of her
i was watching was right outside my
apartment literally just watching her do
this over and over again of just
all right start start at the end okay
walk towards camera
okay cut let's reset do it again you
know it's just like
and you think just the permitting to
shoot this was in the east village
like this is not some off the beaten
path hidden little
corner of new york like it's the heart
of the city it's like just
for a shot you could have done this on
the warner lot on their fake new york
and
it would look indifferentiable from that
but the rest of that you know there's a
famous shot in that movie where they're
running up the circular interior of the
guggenheim
so it's like it's a new york movie and
they just committed fully it's also not
a low budget movie but
i just remember thinking all this work i
mean this is probably it's probably like
a hundred thousand dollars that i'm
looking at right here
for a shot of her walking down the
street never mind what she's being paid
and whatever
just a setup to get people there and to
block the streets and like impede
people's lives
like she's walking past people's actual
front door that they
i guess just can't come out of for the
next hour or something
it's baffling to me new york seems like
more trouble than it's worth
set visits um and i did one for venom
that was on what they called bullet hill
in san francisco it was for
some of the the stunts
yeah a very cool uh stunt but the way
that they dealt with that one was really
unique because of the time of day it's
exactly that hill that's like super
bouncy
um by the way it's naomi watts i i
apparently all
blonde actresses look the same to me uh
so nicole kidman
redhead oh you're right
apparently all women like the same toys
white girls it's whatever
you know yeah apparently apparently i i
uh
i just don't see faces just hair
well but it's not even the color that
she's a woman actually that's the thing
i have
literally tom hardy i might apologize it
was vindicating
australian kind of once i don't know
go ahead there's no there's no version
of this that looks good for me
you're on the set of on the set of venom
yeah um
and basically what they did for that
like it started raining at one point and
people started just coming out i guess
i don't really remember why people
started coming out on the street or
people were trying to watch
but just constantly people have like you
have to get back in your house and
they're like but it's my i pay rent here
what do you mean i have to get i could
i could walk down the street you're like
no you and they would like people would
eventually leave
but they have no legal right to actually
tell people to stay inside their homes
because they aren't police
so it's basically just a set overtakes
the street it has permission from the
city to do so to shut the street
down and then they just have to tell
anyone who wants to leave their house
that they have to leave like often
though they'll
you know not in the middle of a take but
while they're resetting they'll let
people come out and move around if they
need to but it was pretty wild to watch
like i was like i don't understand how
you're going to manage this when they do
so small there's so many people in it
if i may i dated a girl who was a pa
and if if you do happen to live in
especially los angeles or new york um if
you live in atlanta if you live in a
place where they have a tendency to film
understand this those people
that are telling you please wait or
we're they're locking the street down
that's their responsibility
those are typically first in last out
least paid most worked people on the set
and they're
just trying to do their job please don't
yell at them please don't
take out your frustration on them they
have zero
agency or or any kind of authority to
change
anything about what they're doing
they're just trying to do their job
i've i've seen people just screaming at
a pa and that's kind of like
their job is to just get screened that's
what they do
if you've seen troy filming on your
street go ahead yell abusive [ __ ]
just yell it yell at me
greet charlotte yeah [ __ ]
yeah thank you for watching though
you're great
your work is improving steadily over
time and it's been a joyous
watch
[Laughter]
i have to say i i do love those
those uh those crew members in those
kinds of roles that are that are like
the
you know they're in their 50s and
they've worked on a
thousand movies and and they're all like
i love like the carpentry like the
production design department types that
are
seeing some [ __ ] man yeah exactly they
all they all have that vibe
that everyone i've interacted with has
always been like they always have the
carpenter's tool belt they're walking in
they're like
you know hey bill remember when we did
that picture down in uh
you know down the bay area then and it's
like everything feels like these war
stories
you mean the godfather
[Laughter]
and they were like talking about all of
these blockbuster films that had
terrible experience and i was the only
journalist on set i was like do we want
to be
doing okay i guess we're doing it they
didn't care at all yeah pretty much
they're just like hey you want us to
ruin
any movie for you let's have a
conversation about it i had a bunch of
stuff about the dark knight like there
was just tons of stuff that they were
just like laying on me and i was like i
guess i'll take it
because they didn't report one
conversation did its best to ruin dark
knight for me
one conversation with somebody and it
was a writer
and he said explain to me
the scene where they go in to the stock
market right yes you're thinking of
uh uh the stock market is in
rise third one right yeah yeah yeah yeah
sorry sorry sorry that one third one
when does the stock market open time of
day
morning yeah yeah sure the whole thing
happened movie about the mad dresses the
bat was ridiculous
i just realized but they come out
yeah and the whole reason why they did
that scene was to
set up the thing the the bat glider the
bat plane
that's it my biggest beef with that
scene is how did they get the scooters
inside the stock ma
it doesn't make any sense there's a lot
about that where i feel like christopher
nolan who's a clearly great filmmaker
great writer jonathan nolan especially
he's a great writer
just kind of like [ __ ] i don't know man
it was just convoluted
you ever watch um you ever watched the
um movie pitches on screen rant
they always ask a question like that so
like so wait why are they going in the
stock market first thing in the morning
and then coming out and it's night and
it goes so the movie can happen
i think you sent us the soul on austin
they're so good they're really well made
that guy and and and and not just not
just hilarious like his
comic delivery i just love that wow okay
so we're just gonna go ahead and do
that okay it's so funny but it's also
unbelievably insightful yeah like
critique that yeah from a
from a writing uh sort of integrity like
the architecture of these stories where
they
also i've met execs that speak like that
right yeah
there's definitely people around there
are some things that like
people will say on creative projects
that are like so bizarre that it fits
those things like
some of the the scripted stuff i've
worked on sometimes it's been like well
but this is what the audience expects
so we need to do this you'll be like
what why
what does that even mean but okay i
guess like the audience is expecting
this kind of thing so we want to play
into that
why why would you ever want to play into
what you think
people you don't know expect it's just
so there's some weird feedback feeling
uh
okay i guess you have to deal with that
though right that's like you have to
i love working with every partner i've
ever had i think they're all brilliant
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no i'm saying like as far as like
meeting up with player expectation
right so yeah yeah yeah yeah
is that that's where well there's
different so games are interesting and
unique into well here we go this is this
my pretentious moment for the show the
podcast is starting please
the thing about i'm not recording by the
way
games are interesting in that they're
one of the few areas of design
where your objective is not necessarily
to give people what they want
most design is about tailoring an
experience to be
perfect and you know get out the user's
way give them what they need right now
it's a really interesting intersection
between design and art right because art
is meant to challenge you art is meant
to
you know not give you what you want it's
meant to entertain you by withholding
what you want
games are an interesting kind of middle
ground because i would agree that like
in terms of like what button should we
put jump on
that should probably be on the button
that players expect and you know what
the genre and industry does
but in terms of like what you're doing
in terms of creative choices you want to
surprise them you want to do something
different and bold
so it's really weird there's a lot of
conversations in games development that
are kind of
where do we want to be on that line
because we can give them exactly what
they want and technically that would be
excellent design
or we can give them something that's
mind-blowingly weird and they'll never
know what's going on it's gonna be a
nightmare to teach them anything
and that's art and we kind of have to
kind of straddle the two and kind of
pick a path through them
so do you think design should meet
expectation by and large
that that the holding off the
expectation being withholding
should come from more narrative more
artistic and that
oh no i think you can do whatever like
if you look at like something like dark
souls that's a brilliant example of a
game that's like
intentionally obtuse with its design in
a lot of places but because it's so
fundamentally fair with its other
systems you don't agree with that alana
i don't know that i would call dark
souls
intentionally obtuse
like i don't know that that's the
correct descriptor of
what you know it might be too loaded a
word in fairness yeah obtuse might be i
guess what i'm saying is it's not
it doesn't play itself right it doesn't
give you ever it doesn't it's not an
easy game in that sense yeah but it is
still a system that you can learn and
finesse so it's not like it's
it's
there's an argument that like good
design takes less learning
and again this is all like objective
this is sorry all subjective and all
ultimately with games what's interesting
is
you break all these rules all the time
but if you think about any other product
in your life
if i said to you i've got this new phone
and it's it's excellent i mean it's
going to take you a few
weeks to figure it out but once you do
it's going to be the best game
it's the best phone you've ever had no
the conversation of this game gets good
but you have to put in 30 hours
sure and but what's interesting with
games isn't it interesting that games
actually we
that is a valid argument dark souls is
an excellent game
it just takes a lot of work and that's
it's weird that that's something that's
unique to games i think rather than
and even though they'll watch out for
the same thing though too the wire was
like listen
to the show it's gonna pay off but you
have to it's gonna be season two it's
like what the [ __ ] am i gonna do for 12
months
what's interesting with that and with tv
and film and i i actually had this
conversation with someone quite recently
with with film or television there's a
lot of stuff you can lean on
you know that the person who's going to
watch your show knows to sit on the sofa
knows to turn on the tv go to your show
watch for an hour
so it's with games we have to kind of we
have to make the movie but we also have
to build the theater and tell you how to
use it
like we have to kind of create all of
this design that gets you to
the content and that's kind of that's a
real challenge the wire is excellent but
the wire
and the wire expects a lot from its
audience but it it it also can rely on
the fact that you've seen
procedural cop shows before so it can
use certain tropes certain characters
it's also the anti-procedural though
it is but it's it definitely knows that
you've seen those movies
and tv shows yeah definitely language
yeah
but it's just opposing it it's a
subversion it's not an invention it's
kind of it's
it's playing with that i don't know what
it looks like
like we're watching we're going through
a west wing right now and
i don't i won't make the joke that we
had to cut last time again i'll be good
i watching that you there's so much
about it that tells that it's of a time
but
i was thinking about this last night as
we're watching the season one
uh finale and it's just the pace of it
is just
incredible but even in that like
ratcheting up the tension the entire
time
i think i found myself going every once
while just going
and just checking because there was
something that was happening on screen
that wasn't immediately captivating me i
could kind of like
tune into it on a subconscious level and
still take it in
and it made me wonder like have we
changed
the way that we right are we are we
in different ways because we're now
competing it's not just like
like you said the wire crea was
predicated upon a language that people
understood the law and order the
procedural the hill street blues
all of that nypd blue but this is like
we don't do that anymore because they're
constantly going hey meanwhile the
snyder cut is
four hours long but i was gonna say
apparently it's good the wrong tomorrow
someone sent me a screenshot they're on
tomorrow yeah i'm definitely gonna watch
it i'm very curious i have
no idea i think it seems like it's good
because it includes a bunch of setup for
the characters that otherwise were not
included like almost like it has their
own mini movies inside of it i'm not
sure though but i was gonna say i feel
like
i saw when i saw suicide squad which is
a movie that i couldn't stand
um it felt to me when i walked out and i
was trying to think because i didn't
even finish it i literally walked out of
the theater and went and saw a different
movie instead
uh i was trying everything once in my
life that's also the only
time that i've ever done it yeah i can't
think of i've ever i've ever
thought i'm i'm i just have to be
somewhere else i walked out of say
anything but that's because i wanted to
chase a girl
because she was sitting next to me and i
was like we had okay i was like going to
get out of here anyway continue
oh okay i thought you meant you
literally chased a woman out of the
theater and i was like i should address
this
no get out of here and i was like like
john cusack just did it for her i guess
i was like yeah
whatever you want to be great suicide's
fun
i love that i love that you're
completely like she's super excited by
this other guy and you're like
i'll take it like i can meet you i can
work with them
i will be that for you i'm 14
please if that if if my game is being
that dude
fine by all means go for it um
suicide squad felt to me and i i you
know i have no idea if this is the case
but it felt like a result of tick-tock
it's a movie that characters often
rarely even properly interact with each
other it hardens you know
do you know the [ __ ] all the time do you
actually know do you know the actual
story of because you're not far off just
an opinion
so what they did so i mean obviously
you've always got to take everything
with a picture
the version i've heard is that they made
the movie
shot shot the movie did the movie and
then they had um
they they had a very successful trailer
that was produced like the first
announce for it everyone loved that
trailer the film studio then got the
trailer house who've done the trailer to
re-edit the entire movie
wow so a lot of the stuff in there
apparently there's i mean that's the i
think that's the new one that the guys
who
you know the the fans who've gotten the
schneider cut released are now like
demanding the suicide squad cut right
because essentially that's uh
that was kind of butchered together in
that kind of trailer aesthetic so it's
exactly what you're saying
that's true it makes sense trailered it
up the whole and basically made an
hour and a half trailer for a movie they
really did it's kind of what that film
is so disjointed and it's really fast
like it but i can understand an audience
really i can understand younger people
really liking that and i like a slow
movie i like the irishman the whole way
through i'm getting old
this by the way is totally what older
people said about like empty
verification of movies when we were kids
sorry about that [ __ ] about it i'm just
saying this is the death
is this the death of cinema or is it the
evolution thereof seriously
like is it never die it's gonna keep
evolving yeah
so it's this is an evolution of it it's
not something that we should fight it's
just something that's like this is where
we're at this is
art should play to the zeitgeist
therefore so it could be consumed by it
i don't believe that art should always
hover
above i believe that it should make
people look up but i don't think this
should be out of reach for people
that that to me is not art that's
masturbation that's you
doing something creative for your own
self but if you want to say something to
the world you better be able to say
it's all
i think that uh i would like a place for
all of those things to exist like i feel
like it's not like i want all art to
move in one direction and all films to
to move in the same direction i would
i would just welcome more different
kinds of them basically sure like i i
lars van trier sure all day long make me
think be
esoteric totally fine but at the same
time i i do want
lars vancouver is making a movie for
lars van trier he's not making movies
he's moving he's making moves to be a
commentary on something
and he doesn't care if you figure i
don't know this is a whole separate
conversation rod certainly did a whole
thing about this about
austin you want to say something oh i
got i've been i've been racking up i've
been racking up the thoughts
i lost i've been trying to i've been
trying to keep all the thoughts
all the reactions in my head uh strange
it's like exit ramps off the freeway
you're like [ __ ] i got a double back
yeah no for real there's a few that i'm
like i think that one's a lost cause
but uh because because because probably
10 minutes ago
mike you made this kind of declaration
that art
is is sort of it is designed to
challenge you you kind of you kind of
framed artist that's what art is or how
i define art
yeah that's a very personal i'm sure
lots of people have different opinions
but that's my take on it yeah that was
why i wanted to ask i wanted to pick at
that a little bit because i
i i well no i know i really wanted to
talk about xbox with those
today i did the background and i was so
hopeful i was like
it's skyrim we're gonna talk about this
we can do it
we can do it uh
austin challenged me i don't know that i
have a challenge
to it i just wanted to poke at it to see
uh because i think it's an interesting
notion that that art
is that there's a there's a there's a
presupposition of it being
challenging to be art and that so then
the question becomes okay
let's take something i would say to be
good art it should be challenging i
think everything's art i'm definitely
one of those pretentious kits who
who thinks this glass is art if we say
it's art like i don't think
i think it's me i tend to agree with
that i tend to i tend to be on this so
yeah i would say i would qualify that as
i think good art is generally
challenging what do you mean by
challenging then i look i made a short
film this weekend
i'm so proud of you for that by the way
i saw that [ __ ] kick ass thank you it
was really fun uh very short very simple
for my first one it's like it's very it
was very easy um but i did that
intentionally but
i would say out manhattan and have
exactly me yeah
that was you it cost me like two grand
in total for the whole thing that was a
la they're outside your window you just
can't tell
straight apart is that nicole kidman
oh my god it's a lot of peers it is
definitely an accurate expression of
something and my intention is to express
something but i am not trying to
challenge people with my expression i am
just trying to express it
would it be challenging and that it is
showing people that expression like what
do you how do you define i think
yeah i think my chat my definition of
challenging is probably quite broad
because i think i think if you're
if you're expressing something personal
to another party and asking them to
listen
there is to me an element of challenge
in that that you are kind of
challenging them to join you in your
world yeah no it's it's not
it's i'm not saying every piece of art
needs to be like a punk punch in the
face
but like yeah i think art generally
should be
by the virtue i think it's our it's but
it's
it's there's there's a degree of kind of
arrogant defiance to creating anything
and expecting anyone else to be
interested in it
so by definition there's kind of a
combative element to
the production of art design i would say
is more about
um industrial design or just design in
general is more about
uh making people comfortable and about
making you know providing that space for
someone else
the i guess the the difference is art
generally centers the artist
and what they're trying to say and what
they and how they're trying to challenge
an audience
you're going into their place whereas
designers
if i'm making art i'm coming to you and
i'm telling you what i'm doing
if i'm making design i'm welcoming you
in and i'm asking you what you want
it's a slightly different mindset i
would say i've often thought of it in in
a certain way the
in the reverse some of the most
compelling art for me has been something
which holds up a mirror and exposes
something very uncomfortable
about myself so it's challenging it's
challenging me but it's not it's not
it's not because it's at least i i get i
get to the same place that you're
describing but when you say
it's about bringing the audience to you
as the artist and kind of hear me but if
the takeaway is
they've actually made me think about
myself and maybe they've exposed
something
i'm very uncomfortable with about myself
or they've made me realize
you know you know i i've got i i'm very
underdeveloped in this particular
line of thinking or whatever like it's
really not about the artist
very quickly is about their statement a
designer would welcoming you
in and say austin you seem like a really
well adjusted chill guy do you want to
sit in that comfy chair over there can i
get you something
like that's the design mindset it's a
different it and to be clear like all of
this is
massively massively subjective like and
i'm sure there's a million well that's
why yeah
that's why i wear both hats when i'm
making a game
i'm largely i'd say my games like are
over 50
design because essentially i'm trying to
give the player an experience that's fun
and entertaining
and then i'm sneaking in some opinions
and some world views and some
choices that are for me that are kind of
a creative choice and expression from me
but mostly i'd say my games are
designing that they are
about trying to get you know people to
buy them and play them and have a good
time you know
do you think do you think therefore that
you are
the the onus of iteration of evolvement
um innovation leans
more on the artistic and the narrative
side than it does the design side
is the design side it's like we're not
going to try to like really advance
this component we're gonna allow
narrative and art um
style to to kind of do the heavy lifting
for that
design is here to make sure that you can
successfully
experience this this thing
i think or is it like i really want to
shake up the way that we design
i think all is valid i think that goes
back to the kind of it depends what
you're trying to do i think ultimately
they're using a lot of the same muscles
creatively like to do both things like
the skills you're using to make
something incredibly well designed and
player focused
are the same technical skills as you'd
be using to produce art that expressed
your opinion very well like i think
those
those skills are interrelated but i
would say actually if you look at a lot
of like quote unquote successful games
so games that have reached large
audiences or have made lots of money
they generally choose their battles and
they generally go
okay um we're gonna tell you
we're gonna tell you a story about um
parenthood and loss
but it's a zombie shooter you know what
i mean like and therefore we're gonna
meet you on your ground
or you go uh we're gonna make something
innovative and fresh that changes the
very face of gameplay
but we're gonna say in kind of a sci-fi
spaceship that's a bit like star trek
you know what i mean like and you kind
of
you you you choose your battles and you
do choose like what's the area
i can't think of many games that are
both innovative like design
wise and in terms of their interactions
and what the game is
a little bit of sugar you have to decide
which one to me yeah you're trading that
off
i think i think i feel like inside is
the quintessential example of one where
the
design and the narrative are the same
thing
that there's there it's very little of
that
vacillation back and forth that you're
kind of hinting at you know like you
said
it's a zombie inside is definitely a
very simplistically designed game right
and and and to be clear with utter
respect like
it's very well done but like it is just
moving to the side and jumping and some
cool cool composites
when i say just it's very well achieved
but it's not i wouldn't say it was an
innovative platforming game right like
very smart about inside's design is that
it gives you very complicated puzzles
with that
very very very simple gameplay so you're
right that you are ultimately moving
left and right but there are rooms that
you can enter where you have no idea
what to do even
with the limited amount of controls that
you can have i always think about that
part of the line
where you're having to uh basically copy
the person in front of you exactly in
time
it's like that's so simple you know
exactly what you have to do when you see
it when you're in that line you know
what to do but it's it's just a tap of a
butt
and i feel like that's the the genius of
inside design is making
complicated things out of extremely
simple controls
and that's the thing telling their story
that that's the thing
that i love like what you're doing is
how they are telling the story that's
what to me makes it like
next level but the design crucially like
when a designer
or a creative person in general says
something simple that's not a criticism
like
there's an elegance and beauty or
something that like i look up to
anything that's achieving those things i
you know i think i think it's a it's a
bit of advice i give to indie devs a lot
of the time is try and do
one thing really well and start there
and then as you go through the career
you might be able to do multiple things
but like
it's that cons conciseness of vision and
objective and
yeah i'm gonna make something that's a
crowd please or i'm gonna make something
that no one's gonna like but i'll say
everything i think about this weird
subject
those are both equally valid kind of
objectives to have one has more
commercial success likelihood um than
the other but that doesn't that's not
the only metric for success
on the creative working if anything it's
probably interesting
do you also find that
good examples of good design are the
ones that
do not require a ui in order to
so i don't subscribe to that i i know a
lot i know lots of people do
and i think i think it's an absolutely
again like these are all like valid
objectives i'm asking you for your
opinion though i think i think video
games are
input output systems and therefore
removing one of the key outputs
kind of i don't see the i don't there's
i i think it's
it's like being really like we've made
this car it doesn't have a steering
wheel
yeah but okay but i have questions
inside perfect example there's no like
uses we're going to slow you down real
quick so i guess what i'm saying is i
don't think that's in
i don't think a lack of ui is in itself
like a lack of we're just it's i don't
think it's a positive or a negative i
think it's an aesthetic choice i don't
i don't think it's noble to not have a
ui or that it's some kind of purim
i don't feel i don't get more immersed
in games that don't have ui i've seen
that said a lot in reviews and stuff
that like
oh this game doesn't have a ui therefore
it's really immersive immersing me into
the world most of the time when i'm
playing a game without ui i'm confused
or missing information
that's there there are exceptions inside
a good example i mean i don't think abzu
has uh
much yeah nor journey johnny yeah so
it's like journey doesn't even really
have a pause menu i mean it's just like
just playing
yeah i feel like i would agree that it's
an aesthetic choice and it can be
like a good aesthetic choice but i don't
think that it makes it any better than
games that don't have ui
i wanted to jump back to dark souls when
you talk about things that it does that
are complicated and things that it does
that are simple
narratively a mess and i will not
take any counterpoint to that internet
people if i have to watch yeah yeah yeah
you can get into it but if i have to
watch a three-hour video to understand
your narrative
it's told in a way that's inefficient
um but that's a choice that they made um
the menu systems can also be a little
bit convoluted there are items that you
can get that you don't know what they do
that you need to get to a certain point
that will do so
you have no idea what any of this stuff
is but the actual combat itself in dark
souls is
so simple and that's why it works
everything else around it is very
complicated
yeah yeah it's it's so it's just so
precision based it's it's just a matter
of figuring out what does this boss do
when i get to it
here are the the same map of controls
that i have with whatever weapon i've
specialized
how am i going to approach this fight
that is such a simple thing that is just
the true line of dark souls
if you couldn't rely on that then they'd
lose you very quickly
when the cameras go up in those games
like sometimes the camera's bad and
sakura when the camera's bad and sakura
versus the camera being bad and
darksiders is a
oh my god i hate this but it happens in
a few fights but generally
very complicated game very simple
driving mechanic which is the reason
people
where it gets mind-blowingly weird is
when you realize that there are games
with
what would arguably be described as bad
game design
that is the reason for the success and
the great the best example i have of
this
is minecraft his minecraft doesn't tell
you
how to make anything no man's sky no man
no so no specifically i'm calling out
minecraft because they don't tell you
how to how the crafting system works in
game
they probably do now but when that game
first came out versions they do on
okay when it first came out on pc when
it first came out on pc there was no
information in the game there were wiki
pages but there was nothing in game
and what that did was it forced everyone
to talk about it
and it encouraged this community and it
built up and i think there's a real
issue
with my design though or was that i
don't think i don't i think a lot of
things in minecraft weren't by design
but it was
but it worked out like it's arguably the
design strength of that what if we just
said windows 98
and just we're done what if we just
aesthetically made it look
intentionally bad it was like ah you
know
you don't point to that decision i know
games designers who've intentionally rem
like not put tutorial in their games to
try and encourage the same behavior to
basically go
here is a game that you're going to have
to go out into the community and find
out information about
and share and like people will have put
like you know social capital on being
the expert in how to do things
and that encourages those communities
and you see that a lot with the games
that do
very well with online and with community
stuff they're
incredibly obtuse and they encourage
players to go out and have conversations
it's an interesting thought because in
theory bad
design which like i'm sure when you say
it that way it's like what you were
taught at school
can become a positive absolutely by
virtue
of discovery yes yeah but that's the
thing i loved about minecraft when it
first came out like
you know ages ago uh i feel like it was
a whole other lifetime i still worked at
mcdonald's when i was playing minecraft
um i don't know 14. uh
that i didn't know what things did and
as i discovered those things i was
amazed and you could argue that like
like i said that that's
bad design that you would not be taught
at university but it's part of why i
loved it so much that takes us back to
what i said right at the start right
is is in video games that
often the best design basically you
could design the fun out of any video
game just by making the
if you if you made the ux experience of
any video game perfect there wouldn't be
a video game left because the gun would
shoot itself
the character would run forward because
we we'd optimize out all of the
all of the the friction and the noise
and the busyness and the content
and that's what's really interesting
about about video game design is
yes you're absolutely right minecraft
with a tutorial that explained every
single crafting mechanic to you before
you needed to do it and you were just
going through a checklist
would be a worse game and then some
versions it does that they aren't
so fair enough you have to do it oh
that's good
but it's but yeah i think video games
occupy this really interesting space
where
we have to we're making imperfect
systems for you as a player to fix
and that's pleasurable as a player you
enjoy fixing our system
and figuring out how to make things work
there's a really good school of game
design theory which
is exactly that is games are
you know a beautiful machine with a cog
taken out and we and
your job as a designer is to create the
machine around someone but make sure
that they can place their cog in the
middle of it and switch the whole thing
on
i think i think that's it's an
interesting kind of metaphor for how we
work because you can
i've done that before and i've worked on
prototypes where you realize you've made
something that's beautiful and
interesting and when players
watch someone else play they think it
looks great and the second they get
their hands on the controller
it's boring because it just kind of
plays itself and it removes the content
i think that that that whole i'm still
very preoccupied by your
thought on the um sort of that that the
player expectation component to all of
this and the idea that we are
we're in this kind of dance of
subverting or undermining their
expectation in one moment and also
giving them exactly what they want
like like i think that dark souls is an
interesting example because if they made
it easier
it ceases to be what defines it
so the the the the you know it would
broaden the audience while losing its
core audience basically while losing its
and and losing the audience that it's
clearly primarily designed for i even
watched a
youtube video analysis of specifically
well that genre the souls-like so-called
genre you know of
of um saying how they make this
conscious effort the conscious decision
to make peace with and be okay
with sacrificing a wider audience for
in favor of a deeper experience for this
audience like that that's just clearly
part of the calculation because you
can't
mainstreamize it and that that like you
know to the extent and that that's
that's just part of the design
sort of ethos and isn't that interesting
though like in terms of like how
in the video games world that's a
controversial opinion
you know we wouldn't we wouldn't we
wouldn't think that if a film directive
scorsese and
he does often make comments like this in
public right if scorsese
said in public my films aren't for
everyone they're
you know i'm making them for the people
i make them for and
i you know i'm not gonna make my stuff
more accessible even i'm not using that
word in the kind of the sense of
controls but like in terms of people are
being interested in a film
we would we wouldn't blink we wouldn't
think anything of that but because games
are design
because games are products that are to
be experienced by people
in a very direct way there is an
expectation and and
when you when when i hear um people talk
about dark souls and say like there
can't be an easy mode because
we're in the experience or whatever for
some players i feel uncomfortable with
that same and i'm like well
that sucks that we can't let more people
in that feels like we though surely
there's a way of doing that
and that's something i would never say
about you know um
you know i'm trying to think of an
example of like you know a particularly
pretentious movie that i enjoy like i
would never say like oh
yeah but i also think it's the real
thing our
bar for these things moves this is kind
of related also to something i was going
to bring up when we were talking about
is it art is it not art
because sometimes things that are very
challenging in whatever
particular way we're defining it over
time because because the bar
is moving suddenly now a thing feels
very pedestrian
which at the time you know shook the
world apart you know what i mean i mean
that's that's
that's um that's uh that's kind of the
pattern right that's sort of the whole
point of challenging things is so that
eventually you kind of age yourself out
as being uh as being a front line you
watch
this and kane and it feels cliche
because it just set up so many things
that now have become the norm in how
films are made right
yeah i i to that end i was i was
watching
um a one of these you know
game maker tool kit type videos the
other day and they were talking about
um the the moment this is spoiler
in system shock 2 so you've had you know
a 20 21 year old spoiler or
whatever um but there's the moment where
you know the whole
the whole game you've been having this
radio voice
of someone talking to you and then you
come into this room and you find their
dead body and then the walls come down
and showdown reveals herself and says
you know
ha ha for it was i and uh
and the in the video the guy was like
this was one of
the most amazing moments i've ever
experienced in a video game
ever and so i pinged uh
senor levine about it and i said is this
something that you
feel particularly proud of still to this
day like is that one of the because this
guy's describing it like it changed his
life
and and can surprise me because he said
internally this was really controversial
because the conventional wisdom is you
cannot
ever lie to the player and we've been
lying to them up to the whole point in
the in the game at this
stage and now we're pulling back the
curtain and revealing it and it was like
wow what a little wonderful kind of uh
microcosm of the evolution of the
industry because to me i wouldn't bat an
eye about that if someone's like you
know
you know if anything you would say
that's a bit cliched isn't that like at
this point right because it's been done
so many times since
yeah um yeah yeah i think that i thought
yeah to me it was so funny to
imagine people arguing over like we
can't do this
art does transform into design over time
that's the other aspect that's
interesting in terms of like you you
would
things that you would consider i mean
design often kind of will take
tropes from art movements of the past
and and commodify them essentially
so you'll find you know you if you go
and i don't know
look at uh the marketing here uh burger
king right just rebranded
with this with this new logo and font
and
shapes and stuff the shapes and stuff
i'm a professional graphic designer
um they uh they just rebranded and and
for them it's kind of this retro feel
and it feels kind of cozy and
comfortable
but that's the that's like a 70s um
outsider
uh art style and kind of it's based on
kind of scenes and
poster art and kind of late psychedelia
right into kind of 70s soul music kind
of aesthetics that that's pulling from
there were you know controversial art of
their era that has now been commodified
and turned into
industrial design that's used to sell
burgers to middle-aged people
and but that's interesting and that's
something that this is all constantly in
flux we're also such a young industry
which i know is a cliche to bring it up
but like
we don't know what's going to be the
standard we've we've
we haven't had our citizen kane so to
make a big statement we haven't
we haven't found the shot in the first
shot yet you know i i know that's
yeah i totally i totally disagree but i
disagree on the premise that citizen
kane represents the apex
of the art form when people say like
when the last of us came i see it i
think there's so many
citizens is the codification of
codification of an art form right
because it's in kane in basically
created modern cinema or is the
thing that people keep referring back to
right but it's often spoken about 41
yeah but i think that it's also spoken
about as
if it's such a cliche i'm so sorry thank
you six six and kane into the
conversation
this podcast was so good for so many
episodes and then i said citizen
and now it's destroyed
in other words in other words we had our
citizen kane moment several
20 episodes ago and now we've now we've
gone stale now what that was that was
our transformers the animated movie
moment the
the last work of orson welles that's
fair enough great
yeah no i i i my simple contention there
is that citizen kane is often spoken
about as
if we're supposed to accept that it's
the best movie ever made you know afi
very famously declared it the
best film of all time and i think your
point is far more
on point that it represents the
modernization of the language of
uh film and cinema and and filmmaking
techniques
um more than it represents the apex of
how to tell a story with film but even
then
all the the overwhelming majority of
great films were still ahead of us in
1941. of course yeah better films many
better films but that was kind of an
interesting foundational work and i
think that's what's interesting with
games and why i work in games and not
anything else
is because i don't i think it's all to
play for i don't think anything's locked
in yet i don't think we've got
ages to go it's true i often i think we
can genuinely like
invent [ __ ] that defines the next 100
years of interactive entertainment if we
are that smart and if we make something
we couldn't agree more every game is
still ocarina of time
there's so much more that we can make
that could be the next ocarina of time
and half life
there's a wide open field whereas film
it's like what are you going to do make
the best film of the last five years
that sounds boring
just citizen kane again well that's
where i think games also have an
advantage because what defines a game is
so much wider
than what defines a film like we have
like the the sentence i always bring up
is you know
the last of us and tetris are both video
games and and
and and there is no spectrum that wide
in film remotely you know you've got the
the most art house film and the most
commercial film
mechanically operate the same way
whereas like the the nature of your
consumption is still
the only the only breadth i could
imagine is you know
the difference between a long-form tv
show and a film
is is a different experience and you
tell a story over the course of several
years versus over two hours
but it's still fundamentally filmmaking
games offer
like you said we haven't even invented
most of them yet the analogy that i like
to draw is
that games where as an industry
collectively we're like teenagers right
now where we're smart enough to be
precocious and presumptuous and probably
quite arrogant in our abilities but we
also don't think anything can hurt us
so we're up we're just going into the
world with this reckless abandon and
wild inventiveness because
it's like there's no rules there's no
norms there's no standards and practices
and things like that let's just [ __ ]
do it
and i'm like yeah i i'm i'm there for
that
i almost feel like we're a bit before
that right now i want more of that give
me more
stuff that that actually uses the power
of video games and
and okay i don't think we're before that
from the simple standpoint that
teenagers can be smart enough to
like there are teenagers that could
build a car for example like they're
like gifted mechanical
geniuses right like so in other words
we're smart enough as an industry
to know how to make viable actual really
good [ __ ] in the way that a
ten-year-old by comparison can't that's
the only way that's the only
distinction i'll i'll draw there do you
feel this is an accurate statement to
say that
whereas this statement is false
fundamentally flawed
games are the the advancement is
predicated upon
tech or it could be limited by tech so
therefore a perfect example is i
remember
um when we finished the sarah scene for
the second time
um neil said we're going to have to
invent
new tech to be able to and they had to
to to
redness in the eyes from crying wasn't a
thing for them
and so them being able to do that they
had to create tech in order to
capture that performance film doesn't
require
the same it doesn't have the same
restriction
right we don't need a certain type
it can like nobody used to
david attenborough's book life on air
it's basically his memoir and he talks
about things like
you know when they were in the early
days of the bbc and
the camera literally could not pick up
anything below a certain threshold of
light
so he goes we were always sweating
because we had these
[ __ ] bright lights on us because you
literally the camera could not see us
otherwise so it's like
so tech absolutely was informing the
aesthetic that
that made them choose because the early
days of the bbc essentially
defined how television is made for all
the rest of humanity
and so the the the the choices they made
about
like as opposed to like the exactly
that's all you got
and how far away from the camera and all
that kind of stuff was so much of it was
a function
of just literally what can we work with
this stuff barely functions
that's an interesting look i generally
think you are super correct though troy
like i consulted on a game last year
where we wanted to have a city
but had to completely cut it because we
didn't have the processing power for it
so it was like a well we we just can't
have this because
the tech isn't ready and that having
that conversation
in i don't know june last year when i
was like so you're telling me that
there's a future
somewhere where we can actually have a
like
extremely bustling million people
new york city in a video game it just
could be 20 years away
we can eventually get there was that a
was that a budget thing or was that it
was an actual tech thing wow but i mean
in theory
you could say it's a bunch every budget
and tech issue is almost the same thing
so we couldn't we could have made the
city
bigger but we would have had to have
gotten rid of virtually everything else
and that's a completely different video
game so technically but
i mean that those restrictions for
budget are reduced to the more
processing power you have and i think
that's so exciting
it's the whole indeed the whole scene
exists because
tech got good enough and the engines got
good enough that we could make games
with one
and the distribution it should you
should be added sure
that changed like music forever right is
is
napster was the proto for itunes that
fundamentally changed that the way that
the music scene worked all of a sudden
you had these bands that were now on the
same level as this and you didn't need
the major record labels
there is an interesting upwards trend
though in terms of like
expectation versus so it is with tech
this is and
i think it's across loads of things but
definitely with games so i just said the
statement like
indie games happen when two people can
make a game two people can make a game
is something is a really interesting
metric to track over time
because in the 70s two people was too
many people to make a game right
then then you see things ramp up in the
kind of the dos era
you see things kind of jump up to bigger
teams then you see it starts to diminish
again once
once uh windows development comes in you
see those numbers go down in terms of
how many you need to make a game
then you see it rise again then you see
kind of unreal and unity kind of hit a
convenience level that young people that
the
small teams can work with and he comes
back down so games are constantly kind
of leap frogging in that way
arguably we're entering into an upswing
in terms of team size where
it's getting really hard to be an indie
development team that's only a couple
people nowadays just because user
expectations are so high um
and then the platforms that we're making
games for again more complicated
and it will loop back down again and
it's kind of so there is this kind of
ongoing kind of arms race and the user
is a part of that because the player
gets to define kind of what's you know
what's a game that's worth twenty
dollars is something that has also
shifted all over the place over the
years as well
so it's got sixty dollars or a hundred
dollars like these these things move
around so in
so many ways so yeah it's it's a really
interesting
thing from that perspective because you
could model a city like new york with
millions of players of characters
walking around
as long as you weren't trying to render
that in 3d on modern hardware right you
could do that
you could do us i mean arguably loads of
sim games do that
um it's a really there's a there's a
whole
other layer of this in terms of
expectations and management of
expectations on how we all
kind of work within that framework sorry
i don't really really have a point i
just want to be
boring
did i intro
of um where tech informs design and
where
limitations actually yield something
really special
i'm sh i i presume i'm just teeing you
up to tell a story mike
but do you guys know what is
what is um essentially the the
accidental invention of video game
difficulty curves
go for it i don't know how do you know
this i think so i don't have that story
now
really it's very simple it was i think
it was the very original
uh space invaders like the arcade
cabinet
because what happened was you know
you've got your little your little thing
at the bottom that shoots the
bullets up at the things coming down and
remember everybody moves in
slow and what happens is the system was
struggling to render all those that as
you killed them they it could render
faster and it sped them up which meant
that the better you did the harder the
game got and that was because the frame
rate was improving as you killed guys
not because the game was designed to be
harder but they realized oh this is cool
let's keep it
and then everyone went hey it's
interesting if games get harder if
you're better at them let's
let's make that design with centipede
the same thing then because the same
thing happens with centipede
probably yeah probably by that point it
had become something they did
intentionally
i've had that on and fought i've had
that unintentionally so obviously in
game development nowadays we try and
stay independent of frame rate because
that's just good programming
but sometimes an idiot like me makes a
game like thomas was alone
and doesn't test it on any other
hardware and we had a fantastic bug in
thomas was alone never
you know years before i came out where
basically if you ran it on better
computers gravity was stronger
because i messed up and made it
basically frame rate was tied to gravity
strength
so when you put it on like a really good
computer you couldn't just like
impossible yeah yeah
i remember having that happen on playing
king's quest one
where you could change the game speed
and on the original computer i was
playing it on like a ibm
8088 or whatever on the fastest speed
you know king graham would walk like
this but then
the game still worked on a you know a
generation later
uh processor and when you set it to
faster you'd go boom and you'd fly off
the screen so fast that you'd
you'd hit some cliff and fall to your
death and you would never even know what
happened
and it was like wow unfortunately there
are still some games that
that do care about frame rates that
extent which is why so many games are
capped in terms of their frame rate even
on like like classic games that
you can't play on pc over 30 fps often
it is because those games would do
exactly that kind of [ __ ] if you unlock
them
no way crazy yeah um all right thank you
everyone this is uh play watch listen
i'm nicole kidman that's naomi watts
that's mike bethel and that's austin
wintry
before we go uh i did have you gonna
comment on bethesda finally
let's talk about bethesda no uh i can't
show it to you guys but i can show it to
you viewers
we have new merch what um
it's this look at me feigning reaction
to it
oh it's so gorgeous i love what they've
done look at that
yeah that is exactly what i want to
drink slash i'm really banking on it
tasting great
oh it's gonna taste brilliant so um
basically uh an artist he goes by
christian.dr photography on instagram
drew this
gorgeous it is me um it's a
really cute cartoon of me sitting on a
chair with fire around me and i was like
i love this and i would like
i would like to buy it please um are we
the fires
i was gonna say we're always it's just
you you're always the fire for a
producer
putting out fire but i loved it so much
that i was like can i buy this and can
we sell it um
so that will now be on merch
launching today i will leave a link in
the description on youtube we'll post it
on socials if you are
an audio listener uh all of our merch
proceeds go to charity we've been
donating to the innocence project
and uh yeah huge thanks to christian
i'll also leave a link in the
description to where you can find him i
just thought this was so cute that i was
like
i would put it on a t-shirt so check it
out
um thank you guys for watching we will
see you all next week
bye